how's he going everyone my name is
Pierre ah anyway we're back I'm Nisha
yada yada sees Asian gotta love my
second decision he was a trader he has
advocated labeled okay but yes I guess
it only works one in a million times
wouldn't you do that I'm in this place
and I know I I know I didn't stop
playing here but I don't know what to do
it's a lying I look everywhere see I
even opened this door three times see
how good painting
but I collected something in these let's
see items I so long I go pull needle we
have hammer in the chipper let's use
those I suppose that Prime I shouldn't
be wasting my lantern I have 1810 about
that but no freaking oil I am screwed in
my bath just saying yesterday I was no
understand gay jokes ready
I thought that it's something with this
bookshelf because it sort of looks
blueish there can you see the bluish
Ness I can see the bluish Ness and I'm
confused
confusion Ness of the bluest Ness
because what am I talking about in this
room there was really nothing else in
yet so I'm like oh it's a book holy [ __ ]
how can I forget this I'm such an
amateur I thought it like oh it's gotta
be some books at you there
I'll iterate these were filled with
books and I was like dip dip dip this is
so much fun rip rip rip rip but no
there's no frickin book I really wait
you I know it's our II I don't know what
I do sometimes
if it is a book that I'm this game is
meet big meanie maybe it's this one it
is no books okay and there I don't think
you can move this so we are going back
sad face and we're out of oil double sad
face yes it's like mmm but then that's a
double sad face right there
I wish I knew where to go I suppose we
can be done here I don't know I am just
beautify okay uh-huh
maybe this painting can be moved I love
cows
anyway cow butts and stuff let's
continue cow butts and stuff that rhymes
I like I like when it rhymes
I'm good with ramps and
what am I still talking I think so
akward loading screen
fancy fancy fancy fancy let's go over
here because I don't really know legs oh
thanks
oh never mind let's go
I don't trust you
let's go actually let's go wait I just
want to see if you can go upstairs
because maybe you need something I I'm
not sure let's go
it's whoop whoop oh you couldn't holy
crap
West Wing let's go
oh god oh god oh god this is so dark you
and I have no oil but I do have a glass
jar okay let's go it's nice and easy no
monster cab the corner
I don't know
nope what about you not in a minute
state station Stefano
I love reading what the hell why did you
throw what's he doing why are you
spinning me around whoa whoa whoa whoa
what's that you Stefano it's the father
I'm sorry I dropped you Stefano
where are you Stefano Petey I am here
where are you Stefano
Stefano I am here you stupid don't you
ever drop me again stop spinning me
I'm sorry sivanna I really asked there
we go
keep it this way pity now if you want to
get out of this castle you have to do
everything I say
ah and don't wait I'm sorry is it father
hold on I need to pick up the dinner
boxes are you okay yes for now but don't
drop me an acid either
okay so fauna I'm gonna put you down
here
I wanna rotate I forgot I did it two
seconds ago and I forgot oh there we go
you [ __ ] idiot there we go
enjoy staring at the wall Stefano oh
there's nothing here look at the doors I
am looking in the Doris's I think I'm
thinking this is the final thing -
seriously
all right this way pity
yes continue so forward forward forward
you can't ahhh you are an idiot I hate
you
sad face let's go in here
Stefano I told you rap no no that's the
bummer you idiot
this way actually let me do it all air
do their stuff
kinky learner go fella oh it's a fauna
I lost terms ofin ah
which way did he go so far no seriously
though mr. funnel it's not funny
it's a phone or are you in here
I think sofa noise in here
so foul no it's not funny
I was scared
hey Tim sometimes I really closets maybe
something probably not but let's look
anyway draw there's never anything
the sathana was really hurting my boys
guys oh hello faint grinding sound
coming from the other room I bet it's
the fan on having sex who knows he's a
player I'm just saying I know him I know
him better than you guys he's a play
like people like no he's a play he's a
romance no it's a plane I know a fellow
I know Stefan oh I know him since two
second three episodes ago well I guess
we know each other
Stefano is an [ __ ] seriously
okay and I you have to download there's
a hidden door somewhere in the atrium
that can be opened when items are placed
other pedestrians uh-huh
find the key to West Wing I think this
is doing this so it reminds me of that
excited I couldn't heat right they be
back where am I
why have I had an erection this isn't
brennenburg why am i having diarrhea
I must find answers what no diarrhea I
can't use it that way I can't use it
that way all right let's continue
forward because why the [ __ ] not
what's in here I've been in here Stefano
it's not funny it's dark I'm scared
I have panties on me what
seriously though I really don't I'm lost
without you no no no I'm so lost for
words no no no no not you I don't know
the lyrics but I pretend I know them
anyway and I don't even know the melody
so why am I still singing please open
please thank you door you are very kind
boy thank you I like you
Oh remember that sure I do not like so
much
always saluting parts but there's never
anything to loot let's go in here
you see in here Stefano
they found on have you seen stuff I'll
know what I heard Savannah where are you
whoa it's seriously dark here
come on
I need to see something there we go
a box and some stuff okay let's not
waste any just oh how do I rub it I
guess my butt no it does work peanuts
don't that's my kid I throw it ah wait
did I do that anyone that I want that I
want that I had everything I am back I
was with a very pretty girl you'll have
to excuse me it's okay for now say
father I understand I'm just gonna
please you down here and don't you dare
go anyway
sanity potion well well Stefano you have
cousins why didn't you tell me about
them
pity you are screwed leave me with your
cousins nope if your cousin's know
- oh it's you and me buddy I'll keep it
in just for now I did change color
well someone on the streets that's
pretty creepy okay I have a key
it's to take it slow and nice life is
good right sivanna
yes not on the Florida uh-huh and
ah ah how's the funnel did you do that
this time we was used to fun oh I'm so
confused right now what's going on
Stefano listen carefully Polly
I am already scared - but you need to
continue hi hi that was creepy what the
heck is going on ah are you I am the
Hawks again PD I told you not to take
them ok let's take a standard approach
because you really really obnoxious
I don't think our sky by the way I don't
know why I make drunk jokes okay I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry so funny
you really are an idiot it's good here
okay books I hate books
I hate literature I'm sorry books every
day you ought it was okay I'll let you
stay here the [ __ ] was that
[Music]
yeah ask me what it feels like sharing a
disguise so Vendela telling Kurt Russell
homie this ain't real like I'll be
making good on my promises honesty is
pop it in spite of it is missing but I
realized I can be better than I was
later on my feed cooking up the soul
when we fire